time for you to chill out filler style
while kicking butt kc undercover had it
all ever wonder what really went into
the making of such an awesome disney
show we're using some of our own spy
skills to take a deeper look at the
popular show and you may be shocked to
find out some interesting facts that
happen throughout its three-year run so
make sure to keep watching to find out
the biggest controversy surrounding the
series during its first season you won't
believe that such a positive show could
ever have anything negative associated
with it honey
we're also spies
did you know kc undercover was not the
original name of the popular Disney show
when the idea was originally pitched to
zendaya producers called the show super
awesome Katie we're curious do you think
Sunday I looked like a Katy
well the actress didn't think so Sandhya
had a lot of ideas and a complete vision
of how she wanted the show to go the
actress knew what she wanted sunday a
presented disney with a list of demands
including more diversity by having an
all-black family on the show she also
downright refused to have kc sing or
dance
unlike most Disney series that always
centered around a character who sings
and dances she wanted the show to be
completely different well Disney
listened and really took in what she had
to say
not only did Sunday I get the changes
she demanded for but she also got a role
as a producer on the show a rare
occurrence for Disney as well as for any
young teen but Sunday have really
stepped it up and not only was she an
amazing actress she was an awesome
producer her cast mates only had praise
for the young teen and her ability to be
completely aware of even the smallest
details from anything from costume
alterations to script changes the girl
had everyone's back and made sure the
actors were taken care of she made sure
the show remained authentic and
relatable to teens because India was
both we have to say that's pretty
impressive for the dizzies star who at
the time was only 18 I'm a hundred
percent sure about my decision I'm gonna
be a spy
zendaya the producer may have refused to
have our character Casey seeing on the
Disney show and wanted to focus on the
teen super spies talent like martial
arts and kicking buzz however the
actress herself is actually an amazing
singer the
a star has even recorded her own studio
album and in 2017 starred alongside the
handsome and talented Zac Efron in the
musical film the greatest showman
she's got pipes and she's not afraid to
use them
her character Casey may lack in vocal
talent but that didn't stop the leading
actress to be the vocals behind the
theme song of the show another
impressive talent to add right under
producer and actress things that don't
go your way but you always have to keep
focused on your goals
another savvy skills India has under her
belt is fight choreography the actress
did all her own stunts aside from
anything that was considered
life-threatening or too dangerous she
admitted that she usually injured
herself somehow but attempted to do as
many stunts as possible
unfortunately controversy struck the
show after season 1 aired complaints
were made surrounding the stunt woman
that played Sunday as character there
were criticisms that she was white and
several black stunt women accused the
show for its misrepresentation of its
main character a complete was filed with
sag AFTRA that this was unacceptable
seeing as KC Cooper is a black teen who
comes from black parents and has black
siblings in an industry that already
discriminates against women of color
they fought to have a stunt woman of
color be hired instead and in the second
season
Disney ended up doing just that you
could fool me well you didn't because I
know exactly who you are
for the cast of KC undercover a lot of
work happened even before the camera
started rolling unlike typical Disney
shows full of song and dance numbers KC
undercover instead had dangerous stunts
fight choreography rehearsals and
training but there's even more that can
go into just one day of shooting the spy
series a typical day for any film or
television show can be as long as 12
hours per day ranging to as high as 16
to 18 hours for the cast of KC
Undercover their long day starts with a
table read where the entire cast sits
around a very large table and does a
read-through of the whole episode once
that is complete they then go into
rehearsals for each scene on set from
there the actors complete sometimes
several hours in hair and makeup and
wardrobe
once they physically transform into the
KC characters we know and love they head
back to
and that's where the magic finally
happens the cameras start rolling and
they start shooting the show to create
television magic it's a lot of work an
effort to create just one 30-minute
episode being a spy means going on lots
of undercover missions and for every
mission you've always got to dress the
part in disguise of course for the cast
of case the undercover that means lots
and lots of wardrobe changes from punk
rocker to disco diva to an old woman and
even a cowgirl every episode zendaya
goes through a huge range of fun and
very wacky costumes the actors have even
shared an inside look behind the scenes
to show off their characters looks
although regular teenage KC has a simple
wardrobe normally wearing jeans a
t-shirt and some sneaker wedges paired
with her usual plaid shirt wrapped
around her waist her alter-ego Casey the
spy has lots of fun being in her spy
disguises according to the Disney
Channel itself the hour-long episode
entitled tightrope of doom took Sandhya
approximately 11 hours to transform into
four characters in the circus episode in
fact there were nearly 100 costumes
featured in that one episode wowza
that's a lot my style is perpetually
cutting a breeze did you ever wonder
what Casey actually stands for turns out
it's Katrina Charlotte although it's
never actually spoken in any episode
according to several fan pages such as
fandom comm that is Casey's real name we
can confirm that in season 1 episode 7
however Casey's father Craig actually
refers to her as KC Coretta Scott King
Cooper turns out her middle name is a
tribute to the late Coretta Scott King
Martin Luther King Jr's wife and a
leader in the civil rights movement from
the 1960s a very fitting name for a show
that zendaya thought to be diverse with
an all-black family we think mrs. King
would be proud okay I don't know what is
wrong with you people
but if you think my parents are gonna
pay some big ransom you are sadly
mistaken
zendaya has admitted in an article with
variety that she grew up watching that
so Raven another classic Disney show
from 2003 she revealed that she learned
a lot of her comedy from Raven and her
show
turns out the executives of KC
undercover were also the creators of
that So Raven and knew that zendaya was
a huge fan at the former Disney Channel
star she considered Raven her idol not
only as a performer but as a person so
when Disney reached out to Raven to be a
part of the show they knew how much that
would mean to zendaya executive producer
Rob Lauder Stein called it his gift to
the lead actress Raven came on for a
two-part episode and producer said the
actresses performances were like a
classic buddy comedy most memorably when
they dressed up as old janitors for a
scene in the episode Sunday I confessed
that Ravens presence on set pushed her
to step up her acting game and really
get creative with her performance
knowing she based her comedy off of the
veteran Disney actress she said it made
her try new things and really discover
herself in the process did you know that
zendaya is one of a handful of Disney
stars who have acted in more than one
Disney show the actress is known for her
lead role as KC Cooper but in 2013 she
also had another lead role starring
alongside Bella Thorne in shake it up
she even had a role in one episode of
the short-lived Disney series ant farm
back in 2011 it's not an easy task for
actors to achieve this it's already a
tough industry to break into just
getting an audition for a Disney role
can be tough let alone getting a part -
on top of that most Disney fans have a
hard time seeing the actors of their
favorite characters in different roles
from other shows
fortunately for zendaya the girl made it
work and was able to transform herself
into different characters for each show
like most television show and movie sets
an actor is usually surrounded by an
arrangement of items and props
although the audience believes they are
looking at a room or location that may
appear real but the majority of items
are fake a lot goes into every detail of
every prop piece of furniture of every
one room the character inhabit some
items can be real such as a refrigerator
or stove and others are
completely fake in case the undercover a
popular set was the hangout of Casey and
Marissa elf Royal Oak Oh a frozen
ice-cream shop although most of the set
was fake like the frozen yogurt
dispensers items like candy bowls were
actually real other sets like the Cooper
family living room they have things like
staircases that lead to nowhere
but photographs that were displayed
around the set and even hung on the wall
were actual photos of the cast photos
displayed throughout had actual baby
pictures of zendaya at different ages
throughout the set and they're adorable
it is my pleasure to make your
acquaintance I know your hello knits the
secret to the success of the show is
that it was pure harmonious energy what
does that mean you asked everyone got
along and they all loved working with
each other
sadly it can happen so often that
television series have cast mates that
don't get along or there is tension on
set but on Casey Undercover that was
definitely not the case the entire cast
had a deep admiration for one another
and only had praise for each other and
their lead star zendaya when they filmed
the last shot of the finale episode the
cast celebrated with lots of tears and
even tears everyone was happy but also
sad to see the wonderful show come to an
end that is why with the show being so
popular and successful many of its fans
wondered why the show ended after only
three seasons looks like the show stars
India was ready to move on and felt she
had fulfilled what she set out to do and
she was ready to try new things as an
actor there was a lot she wanted to do
in her career and she knew this was her
time to go well there you have it
kaci undercover will always be known as
one of Disney's most beloved
and successful shows that not only
propelled Zendaya's career but also gave
her the confidence to do things her way
what do you think about these fun
behind-the-scenes secrets let us know in
the comments below and thanks for
joining us here at the things